hello Gordon good afternoon customer
right Richard oh Richard I'm sorry first
time we met and Richard you're not a
customer what'd you do I work with Sandy
on ideas for marketing what was the last
big idea you put into the Four Seasons
last big idea we had was purchasing lift
tickets at a discounted rate right I
would have fired you five months ago
coming into the summer what's the next
big plan and I can present plenty of
plenty of ideas but he has to accept
them I'm frustrated I feel that the
ideas I bring to him are helpful they
would work but Sandy he's just not
listening and here's your salmon
excellent thank you my day enjoy thank
you thank you
good God I hope it's at least halfway
good
as a apple risotto
wow
what a punish it that sums it up on that
plate there he's as good as Chef as he's
an Innkeeper
[__] useless I can't believe I've not
seen Sandy once through my whole meal
what sort of innkeep of nausea's guess
and hides in the kitchen well if you
won't come to me
just give me that knife now
hi guys hi I'm Steve Dixon Steve good to
see you bud Bill good to see you too bud
I'm trying to get a grasp on what I've
just eaten I know you're the owner yes
but you're the head chef as well as
we're working together now in town
so you're both head chefs I've I'm
not I'm not exactly sure where I fit in
it it's not my menu I'm not doing any
ordering filled with Sandy right now a
little thrown under the bus I feel a
little betrayed right now
the risotto was sweet what's in there
apple juice apple concentrate Chef apple
concentrate in a risotto
yes sir come on it's not my menu chef
so this is all you're doing then yeah
oh my God so it's pretty big right so
how are you supposed to get it in your
mouth
I've never eaten it before let's try
come on me we're in this together oh no
you order this one all on your own
that's yours
ready open one please wait there is no
way this is going to fit my mouth ready
one two three
I can't do it
now I don't know how my granddad feels
with [__] new teeth
can I throw it away now
so you took one little bite I did damn
disaster total disaster how did it taste
by the way I'm very good the Sakura is
very chewy Suki does tried her best but
she has no idea what she's doing what's
wrong with the Sakura Bland ugly chewy
strange combination chewy
yep been impossible to put in your mouth
let me tell you about my sushi I'm not a
Morimoto or Noble absolutely I'm doing
my best and I respect rice what is this
one strawberry field now look at that
Aubrey on sushi
Japanese Chef in America I'd like to
apologize it's very weird which part is
so true you wouldn't cover white tuna
with strawberries and then glaze it
Strawberry Fields rather [__] eat a
beetle
it's too sweet strawberries don't belong
with tuna I am frustrated that Gordon
does not like my Sushi I've tried all I
can
just have any little samples of like
wine flights anything Regional we've
talked about that but we have not
implemented it
so you've been talking about it for nine
months but you haven't actually done it
yet no one's even bothered the sort of
wine flights or trying to get it
together so you've got this place almost
a year and you haven't implemented
something that this town thrives on
correct right
have you tasted as a skunk I mean yeah
not really have you eaten I mean you eat
here right not very often when was the
last time you guys sat down and had
dinner in the restaurant never sat down
with all three of us together Australian
stranger I'm getting slightly nervous
that nothing actually gets done here
anyway I'm living in hope I have some
more bread for sure
I got a lampshade coming right out bro
oh my God
[Music]
holy crap what is that this is our lamb
shank that's a weird looking lamb shank
visually it looks like the biggest plate
of puke I've never personally had lamb
shank ever being here I do not like lamb
you're the Russian manager you don't
like lamb don't eat yeah I'm the
restaurant manager but I'm not I'm not
the chef wow I think I would just call
that a dog's dinner what a mess
I do apologize again
I'm totally embarrassed that our food is
this quality I've always thought it was
better hey Joel yes it's the lamb shank
he mentioned that the vegetable gravy
goo was a little little too much oh okay
I'm gonna run this out okay
so fine dining Frozen and edible nasty
Extra Man I mean I'm amazed what's this
one this is the calamari Dore steak
that's not garlic in there again is it
there is garlic in there again jeez it's
just how that dish is prepared
everything's just laced with garlic
please
be my guest this
what is it trying to be a sponge
what's that it's a three-tier Tower of
three different appetizers and is his
name big enough on the menu there
obviously suffering from small man
syndrome let's go for that and then the
bassinet ravioli let's try that all
right nice to see you
so the appetizers first place okay well
I'm feeling really nervous about cooking
for Gordon it's real [__] froze
together most of the food is
pre-packaged or canned or frozen because
Ginger and Philip are running this place
like real misers they uh Pinch A Penny
on every corner
this is our crab and artichoke dip it's
served with deep fried pita bread and um
is it fresh crab or canned frozen chili
and crab frozen chili and crab correct
a [__] snot dip
I mean it's like a dish ready for one of
Phillip's girlfriends no teeth oh God
it's got a sour taste to it I don't know
what it is I know Jesus
he felt it tasted sour it always got
that taste of me I don't like it
you are kidding me
this is the tower this is the tower oh
my gosh holy Mackle so
um
you should open your [__] Garden or
your restaurant are those shrimp are
they fresh or are they frozen they're
frozen they're frozen damn
[Music]
and what's in here they're teriyaki beef
tips
sauces hideous and that's just tough
beef chew and that middle one's another
portion of snot dip I'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu
what
the chef doesn't write his own menu he
does not let's move on shall we my God
careful
so Philip's dictating the menu I
supposedly staff can't be trusted to
clock in and out they can't be trusted
to choose the food
feedback on that um the meat is too
tough the sauce tastes weird he can tell
it's not homemade
it's just Ramses
and it is the meat is too tough yeah
he's getting the full picture and that's
just what I wanted
right I feel very good about it I am
very disappointed with Dan's food it's
horrible I just hope that Gordon sees
the problems with his staff
ravioli